Rolls Royce went and had their biggest
year ever Rolls-Royce Herald's momentous
year as Car Sales exceed six thousand
for the first time
for the first time in 118 year history
the company saw particularly strong
you're on your growth in the Middle East
Asia Pacific and U.S and Europe in 2022
with a single digit drop in sales in
Greater China interesting so China
bought few Rolls Royce everybody else
bought more which was successfully
counterbalanced by increased sales in
other markets some 6021 cars were
delivered to customers last year an
increase of eight percent from 2021 with
demand for all models remaining
exceptionally strong in advance orders
secured
far into 2023 the value of uh bespoke
bespoke commissions also reached record
level highs with clients willing to pay
around a half a million dollar half a
million euros for a unique Rolls-Royce
Adam what are their chances of you one
day owning a Rolls-Royce well thank you
for teeing that up you know I was
talking to my Rolls-Royce dealers today
I've got a couple I'm betting them yeah
just to make sure I'm getting the best
deal on the rules
well I will say that you know my voice
they're probably mostly Middle Eastern
100 my Rolls-Royce dealers know your
Rolex dealers they're in communication
uh I don't know what percentage of the
world is even looking into buying a
Rolls Royce six thousand twenty one of
them yeah okay so out of eight billion
out of eight billion yeah this is a very
small Market but I guess where I'm going
with this is we just read the article
about if whether it's a Rolex or an
Audemars piquette or what's uh yeah yeah
or uh
you know you know it's expensive when
you start talking like this yeah
out of nowhere yeah but like the first
things to go are your wants right like
you talked about whether it's watches
anything with the motor cars uh you know
boats motorcycles all that so I guess
I'm my question is I'm grappling with if
all these wants are going down luxury
goods why are roses Royce going up
because my guess is the rich have gotten
richer
poorer like you could be a paycheck to
paycheck guy you can make a hundred
grand a year and you're like you know
what I kind of want that freaking uh
that Rolex and you'll spend some money
on a watch you ain't doing that with the
Rolls Royce Rolls Royce is for the elite
of the elite of the elite it comes with
the drive yes exactly I mean so right
now I'm just negotiating with my two or
three uh Rolls-Royce dealers and jump
seeing what I can come up with right now
but now's a good time to uh to find
these luxury assets on a good family
agree with them the fact that the to the
rich you know by the way I just did a
number right now if a person bottle
Rolls-Royce yesterday 6021 of them sold
we got eight million people you ever
heard that song you're one in a million
you're one in a million you're
officially one in
1.328682 million people about the
lottery how much is a Rolls Royce how
many hundred million yeah half a million
like I'm patches
that's the world the Phantom is going to
be 650. Dawn is going to be 400 Grand a
ghost is going to be 350 drop head you
already dropped you you're looking at
anywhere between 350 to 700 000. how
much is a Maybach maybe is about three
hundred thousand dollars well oh oh by
the way congratulations on the new car I
just saw sitting out there yeah I love
that tell me about that but so you got
rid of one car to get this one no I
didn't get rid of it the other one is in
the garage he's just sleeping it's
chilling I just trying to get rid of it
but this one the Porsche Turbo S it's
sick Cabriolet oh my God ridiculous I am
in love so you're not getting I'm not
even kidding with you I'm in love that's
sick now yeah I mean it's 0 to 60 2.2
seconds comfortable comfortable you have
to sit in it I can't yeah
I'm gonna take you you're going to see
how it goes you have a deal you're gonna
sit there you're gonna say holy [ __ ]
you'll see when it flies it's an amazing
it's so bad when you drive a car that's
worth okay that's a really that's a
house 460 000 literally like somebody's
driving that for you or you're not
people I don't see that many people that
that if that's your car because bro any
dink any anything that's like I'll call
like you have to pay like how much 10
000 so anything on any damage under this
your rims your everything it's
ridiculous first of all when I when I
had the dawn I had a flat tire Tom you
can correct me if I'm exaggerating okay
over a two-year period I drove it every
day yeah how many flat tires did I have
honestly in two years in two years but
two of them are two of them per month
also you weren't you you you you called
Jen right now no I remember that but I
remember the first one where
you call the number you suddenly hear
helicopters overhead guys are dropping
down on ropes and they're suddenly
changing the changing your time and
apologizing I had I probably had 12 flat
tires in two years that's why but let me
tell you what happened here's what would
happen they come they pick it up they go
change the tires no one [ __ ] they
bring it back to you that's uh the
service is ridiculous well I would hope
you get that same type of services
spending a half a million dollars to get
that service with Mercedes oh no you
don't get that service with Mercedes
no no but that's still yeah but you get
the service with them the level of
details like the the leather they use
inside is with cows who have never had
mosquito bites what are you joking no no
I'm telling you oh my no no I'm telling
you like the the stuff the story when
you see the story behind what they do
the floor mats in real wall yeah by the
way the hand like the the what do you
call a steering wheel the leather on the
steering wheel it's like only four
people in the world that sold all of
them on and the way they do it it's like
the more and more you hear those store
everything is like handle the clock in
the middle the watch in the middle the
the level of Ingenuity and detail
so just don't go to a Rolls-Royce
dealership because when they start
talking to you like this you literally
oh you're like you are gonna buy your
Rolls Royce I don't you love Rolls-Royce
you will max out your credit cards and
get a Rolls Royce I don't care if eggs
are expensive Rolls-Royce is cheap
that's what they're gonna do to you and
you're like oh [ __ ] Ma I gotta roll I
should buy rolls I don't know yeah but I
got it it's a Dad's credit so Mom's
credit on the on the inner of the Rolls
Royce on the dashboard you know they
have the the clock it's very fancy clock
it's actually built from human skin that
has never had a mosquito wow
but by the way here's a little tip to
save that money if you're gonna if
you're interested in a Rolls Royce
here's what you do you go to the car
dealership you go you go right up to the
dealer and you say show me where the
Chrysler 300s are yeah you go buy that
same car you go steal the Rolls-Royce uh
Insignia of Pat's car yeah you glue that
on yeah you take your girl not to a hot
date restaurant you take her to Publix
now we're saving that freaking look at
that dude we're driving Chrysler 300s
we're not driving roses we're not eating
out at the fancy restaurants we're
saving money on eggs this is your game
plan for 2023. I think this is good I'll
tell you why I think it's good because
there's a lot of people that are taking
pride in their work who will never own a
Rolls-Royce that are building them and
have jobs at that company yeah and get
back to the biz dog no no I mean you
people say oh the rich are getting
richer yeah but they're buying things
that are built by other people who have
a really good job doing that so I kind
of look at it as as net benefit because
there's there's there are four or five
people that make whatever they make a
year that are sewing leather and they're
doing leather selection and everything
what do you do I do leather selection
for Rolls Royce so it's perfect yeah by
the way once every podcast I try to give
the bizdoc shout out for when he hits
nail on the headphone here we go if you
hate rich people listen to what Tom just
said for all those 6 000 people that are
buying Rolls-Royce is out there how many
jobs has this created whether you're
doing the leather and the wheels and the
steering wheel all this stuff or you're
selling one in Miami jobs are being
created because rich people want love
guys this is totally random but that's
how my brain works do you think those
Rolls-Royce cows know that they're like
first of all zero mosquitoes at that
number two ready for this because all
the other ones are gonna die and go to
whatever and they're like guys
when I die I'm gonna be seats and a
steering wheels boots on some idiot
enjoy your McDonald's so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]